in a world where we are more connected
than ever a threat Looms in the shadows
of Technology from malicious hackers and
state sponsors cyber warfare to
Insidious malware and data breaches the
dangers of the digital threat is ever
present threatening individuals
businesses and governments around the
world well guess what I'm talking about
you guess that right cyber threats of
course on that note hello everyone and
welcome to Simply love in today's
session we'll be discussing what are
cyber attacks and various types of cyber
attacks prevented in today's times but
before we begin if you're into the
channel and haven't subscribed already
consider getting subscribed to our
Channel simply learn to stay updated
with all the latest Technologies and hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from us so without any further Ado let's
get started with today's topic
let us have a quick introduction to what
cyber attacks are now the rise of
digital age has brought unprecedented
connectivity and convenience but it has
also introduced new avenues for
malicious actors to expert
vulnerabilities cyber attacks
encompasses a broad range of militias
activities where adversities leverage
technology to infiltrate disrupt or
compromise digital systems and data so
in nutshell you can say it is a
deliberate and malicious attempt to
compromise computer networks networks
system devices with intention of causing
harm stealing sensitive information or
gaining any kind of unauthored access
and having said that with cyber attacks
becoming more prevalent and severe it
has become crucial to address the cyber
security skill Gap and overcome the
shortage of cyber security Talent so if
you are interested in pursuing a career
in cyber security and acquiring the
necessary skills then our post-graduate
program and cyber security can be the
right option for you well gain expertise
repeat gain expertise in defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics ethical hacking network
security penetration testing and crucial
domains with this internship program our
comprehensive program offers a
curriculum that income passes a wide
range of in-demand cyber security tools
Hands-On labs and guided practices and
throughout the course you will embark on
a well-structured Learning Journey
starting with fundamental cyber security
Concepts and progressing to asset and
inventory management offensive security
and defensive security to ensure your
Readiness for the industry you'll also
engage in multiple projects allowing you
to hone your skills and emerge as an
exceptional cyber security professional
furthermore this course will help you
learn comprehensive approaches to
protecting your infrastructure and
securing data a
mitigation compliance and much more so
why wait hurry up and sign the course
Link in the description box for more
details so make sure you check that out
and let us continue with our topic today
now
so what is the motive behind cyber
security attacks now that we wanted to
watch cyber security acts let us
understand what is the motive behind it
now that digital age as revolutionized
how we interact work and live but it has
also brought new challenges in fences
for victims now the motive behind
several attacks can be widely varied and
they are often driven by different
factors depending on the attacker's
goals and intentions so let us look at
some of the motives behind cyber attacks
now first on the list we have financial
gain now one of the most prevalent
repeat one of the most prevalent
motivation for cyber attacks is
financial gain they seek to steal
sensitive financial information such as
credit card details login credentials or
any kind of personal data which they can
sell on the black market or used to
commit fraud and identity theft where
attackers encrypt a victim's data and
demand payment for decryption keys and
also motivated by Financial key
now second reason is industrial option
age now in the corporate world cyber
attacks is sometimes carried out to gain
a competitive Advantage by stealing
proprietary information Trade Secrets
and intellectual property competing
companies and Nation statewides May
Target organizations to obtain valuable
information and insights
political reasons or any kind of
ideological reasons now hacktivism
involves using cyber attacks as a mean
of expressing political or ideological
abuse hacktivists Target government
agencies corporations or other
organizations to protect or raise
awareness about specific issue they may
deface websites leak sensitive
information or disturb services to make
their points
personal Vendetta or any Revenge now
some cyber attacks are also carried out
by individuals seeking revenge or
retaliation against a person a group of
organization they hold a grudge against
and finally cyber terrorism now in rare
cases cyber attacks can be carried out
as an act of terrorism to create fear
chaos and widespread disruption these
attacks aim to cause significant harm to
society and can Target critical
infrastructure such as power grids or
Transport Systems and much more while
understanding the motives behind cyber
attacks help in developing effective
cyber security strategies to mitigate
and respond to these threats
now how does cyber attacks exactly
happen now cyber attacks are
orchestrated processes that aim to
compromise the security and integrity of
computer systems and Digital Data
attackers gather information about their
targets such as identifying potential
vulnerabilities security weaknesses and
valuable data they can exploit now this
phase involves passive techniques like
searching publicly available information
and active techniques like scanning for
open ports on the targets Network so
regular security assessment timely
software updates user awareness training
and implementing robust security
measures are essential in mitigating
these risk of cyber attacks from
happening
thus cyber criminals are constantly
devising their sophisticated techniques
to expert vulnerabilities in systems and
networks they reduce devastating online
questions for victim so understanding
these threats and implementing proactive
safety measures is crucial for
safeguarding or digital assets and
personal information so here are the
common types of fiber threats that are
provided in the current times in no
particular order now firstly on the list
we have malware now malware encompasses
various types of malicious software
designed to infiltrate systems data
steel and Reserve operations and gain
unauthorized access it includes various
types of uh
viruses worms Trojans ransomware and
spiral Etc now malware disguises itself
as a legitimate files or software to
receive users and avoid detection it can
propagate through infected email
attachments malicious websites or
compromise software
now one of the real world example of
this is in 2017 the wannacry ransomware
attacked thousands of computers
worldwide and cryptium data and
demanding Ransom payments in Bitcoin
so what are the consequences of malware
attack firstly data breaches and theft
of sensitive information next we have
system disruptions leading to long time
and kind of financial losses
and thirdly Espionage and unauthorized
access to personal or corporate Networks
but how can you Safeguard yourself from
happening or protect yourself from
malware so firstly you need to regularly
upgrade your operating systems and
software to patch vulnerabilities also
install reputable antivirus and ulti
malware software and keep them up to
date
thirdly
exercise caution when downloading files
from unprusted sources or clicking on
any unknown links from the websites or
Internet
finally educate users about safe
browsing practices and recognizing
potential Market threads
now second on the list we have phishing
attacks now phishing attacks are social
engineering techniques used by cyber
criminals to trick individuals into
revealing sensitive information such as
logic credentials Financial details or
any personal data phishing emails often
appear to be from reputable sources
including bands social media platforms
or government agencies they create a
sense of urgency of year to prompt
immediate actions so make sure you do
not click any sort of
uh unreputable sources of emails that
you get from any kind of understated
resources
now what are the consequences of
phishing attacks firstly identity theft
and unauthorized access to personal
accounts also Financial losses due to
fraudulent transactions by clicking uh
and
repeat
secondly Financial losses due to
fraudulent transactions by clicking
unknown links from various uh
third-party websites or such
and finally compromise of sensitive
business data and intellectual property
now in 2017 a phishing attack targeted
Gmail users directing them to a fake
login page to steal their credentials so
make sure you stay away from all these
malicious activities
so what are the safety measures you can
take against phishing attacks firstly
enable multi-factor authentication from
all accounts to add an extra layer of
security Now next trick avoid clicking
on any suspicious links as discussed
earlier so you have to train employees
and individuals to recognize facing
emails and avoid clicking on any sort of
unsuspicious links
also Implement email filtering systems
to detect and block phishing attempts
and finally regularly update your web
browsers to protect against known
phishing vulnerabilities by installing
any kind of anti-virus systems
list we have ransomware now ransomware
is a type of malware that encapes our
victim's data making it inaccessible
until a ransom is paid to the attackers
indexical threat to individuals
businesses and government organizations
worldwide now ransomware often uses
strong encryption algorithms to lock
victim's data securely it may be
delivered through malicious email
attachments compromised websites or
expert kits now in 2021 the colonial
pipeline in the United States fell
Victory toward ransomware attack leading
to the shutdown of operation and a
ransom payment to the attackers
so what are the consequences of
ransomware again now again Financial
losses due to Ransom payments can be a
huge Factor where you have to pay a lots
of lots and amounts of payment or money
to the hackers
data loss and potential leakage of
sensitive information and finally
reputation damage for organizations that
experience the successful attacks of
ransomware so what are the safety
measures that you can take against
ransomware well you can regularly backup
critical data to an offline or secure
location to avoid data loss also
maintain up-to-date data software and
security patches to protect against
known vulnerabilities
Implement networks repeat Implement
Network segmentation to contain the
spread of ransomware within the system
and finally train your employees and
individuals to exercise cautions when
handling email attachments and links and
by regularly security audits repeat and
by connecting regular security audits
you can protect yourself from various
kinds of ransomware attacks
now fourth on the list we have DDOS or
distributed denial of service attacks
now DDOS attacks aims to overload a
target's online services or networks by
flooding them with a massive amounts of
traffic rendering them inaccessible to
legitimate users these hackers are
typically orchestrated using botnets now
the DDOS attacks use multiple devices to
create a massive volume of traffic
causing service disruptions attackers
often exploit vulnerable iot devices to
build botlands but what are the
consequences of DDOS attacks firstly
let's say downtime and service
disruptions leading to financial losses
secondly damage to a company's
reputation and customer trust if you
know in 2018 GitHub experienced one of
the largest DDOS attacks in history with
traffic peaking at 1.35 tbps and in 2016
a massive BDS attacker or Des provider
disrupted several major websites and
services
and finally
server and website vulnerability
now diversion of attention from the
actual attack to dealing with the
aftermath of this can also be a crucial
consequence where it your server or
website vulnerability has already been
caused
so what are the safety measures against
radiois's firstly deploy tracking
filtering repeat deploy track repeat
deploy traffic filtering and day
trembling to detect and block malicious
traffic during an attack
utilize content delivery networks or
cdns to distribute traffic across
multiple servers and reduce the impact
of DDOS attacks also regularly monitored
traffic and setup alerts for unusual
patterns indicating an ongoing attack
invest in scalable infrastructure to
handle sudden traffic surges and prevent
service disruptions so these are some of
the safety measures that you can take
against DDOS attacks and help yourself
to protect against
and finally on the list we have SQL
injection SQL injection is a web
application vulnerability that allows
attackers to manipulate the website's
data by injecting malicious SQL code
into input Fields this can lead to
unauthorized Access Data Theft or data
manipulation now the SQL injection is
successful the database might execute
the attacker's injected SQL code
alongside the legitimate query granting
unauthorized access to data modifying or
deleting data or even compromising the
entire database
so SQL injection applies repeat SQL
injection exploits poorly sanitized user
inputs and replication
repeat SQL induction expires poorly
sanitized user inputs in web
applications which can extract modify or
delete data from affected databases so
what are the consequences of SQL
injection well unauthorized access to
sensitive data including user
credentials and personal information
secondly data manipulation or deletion
rendered data and regularity issues and
finally disclosure of confidential
information and compliance violation now
a real life example of SQL injection is
in 2008 SQL injection was used to breach
Heartland premium systems resulting in a
theft of millions of credit card records
so what are the safety measures that you
can take against SQL injection firstly
adopt secure coding practices such as
parameterized queries and input
validation to prevent SQL injection
vulnerabilities from happening secondly
conduct regular security assessments and
penetration testing to identify and
address potential SQL injection flaws
next implement the principle of least
privilege to limit database access
rights for application users so that the
hackers cannot easily
dive into your database and finally stay
updated on the latest security patches
and updates for Frameworks and
applications so these were some of the
top five common types of cyber security
threats that are prevalent through its
times and with that please come to the
end of today's session on different
types of tribal threats I hope you watch
I hope you found this tutorial
informative and helpful thank you for
watching the video guys if you like this
video subscribe
repeat subscribe to our Channel simply
learn for more such amazing videos if
you have any further queries regarding
any of the concepts covered in today's
tutorial in the comment section below
and a team of experts will be more than
happy to help resolve all the queries at
the earliest until next time thank you
and keep